this is the part you want to cut out and
put on twitter
assalamualaikum guys and welcome to an
episode
[Music]
hello you guys been asking for it apus
i i have no muscles here i have no
muscle i
i have no muscles here i have no muscle
so aepos has been dodging muhammad hijab
for quite a while now
but to confront his islamophobia and
hate preaching muhammad
jab had to adopt a slightly different
style with the help of adam saleh and
slim
hijab decided to pay apus a surprise
visit because you don't believe in it
you are also followed and persecuted for
that so it is completely normal that
somebody who leaves this one whose
entire life was defined by the fears
we have a friend here who's more um
is
so if two sisters or two brothers have
incest sexual relationship there's
nothing
i can't see anything wrong with it right
well there is uh actually nothing wrong
with it here
he asked me do you think it's okay for a
for the father and the son to have sex
i said if there was no harm to society
i said yeah so there you have it bro so
forth
because that would imply you
are
you